guten Abend willkommen zu ZDF heute live
jeden Tag prasseln Nachrichten zum
ukraine-krieg auf uns ein teilmobil
machen
Raketenangriffe Luftabwehrsystem es ist
nicht immer so leicht da den Überblick
zu bewahren wir wollen deshalb heute
fragen was passiert gerade an den
Fronten kommt die ukrainische Armee noch
voran bei ihrer Gegenoffensive und was
passiert jenseits der tagesaktuellen
Nachrichten
Oberst Markus Reißner gibt uns heute
Antworten er ist Kommandant beim
österreichischen Bundesheer und
veröffentlicht seit Beginn des Krieges
Erklärvideos die 100.000 fach zum Teil
geklickt werden
deshalb gerne Fragen und Kommentare
schicken einfach in die Chats schreiben
oder per Mail schicken bevor wir mit
oberstreisner sprechen schalten wir
jetzt erstmal nach Kiew und nach Brüssel
zu meinen Kollegen Alissa jung und
Florian Neuhaus hallo zusammen
Alissa lass uns vielleicht bei dir
beginnen als wir am Montag bei ZDF heute
live miteinander gesprochen haben
hattest du gerade mehrere Stunden im
Bunker verbracht wegen der
Raketenangriffe vielleicht kannst du uns
einen Überblick über die letzten 24
Stunden geben
jetzt gerade seit einer Stunde gilt auch
wieder raketenalarm und das war auch
schon den ganzen Morgen und die Nacht
über hat uns das hier begleitet also das
heißt der raketenannahme der wird hier
ausgelöst ganz ganz laut hört man das in
der Stadt und bekommt das aber auch auf
Smartphone geschickt und dann bedeutet
das natürlich das Raketen kommen könnten
und es wird also gewarnt die Menschen
sollen Schutz suchen sich in dem besten
Fall in Schutzkeller begeben und
natürlich haben wir auch jetzt hier in
der Nähe direkt und unten dem Gebäude
einen Schutzkeller aber man muss dazu
sagen dass man natürlich auch ein
bisschen ganzen Tag so in dem
Schutzkeller verbringen kann deswegen
sind schon auch natürlich Menschen jetzt
auch in diesem Moment wenn auch nicht
sehr viele auf der Straße hier ist
ruhiger seitdem seit Montag seit den
Angriffen viel viel ruhiger natürlich
auf der Straße und gleichzeitig trotzdem
haben die Geschäfte auch wieder eröffnet
und das Leben läuft hier weiter so wie
man es in der Ukraine jetzt auch schon
öfter beobachtet hat dass die Menschen
sich hier auch irgendwie mit dieser
dauerpanik die da verbreitet werden soll
von russischer Seite auch irgendwie
arrangieren sie müssen damit irgendwie
Leben und klar kommen und so hat sich
das jetzt inzwischen eingependelt in
immer wieder ist raketenalarm und immer
wieder sucht man dann auch Schutz aber
gleichzeitig läuft das Leben schon auch
wieder an hier
auf dem Punkt würde ich gerne noch mal
ein bisschen näher eingehen was hat das
mit den Menschen jetzt gerade in Kiew
gemacht die ja relativ lange in
Anführungszeichen Ruhe hatten stoisch
trotzig resigniert
und es war schon ein Schock natürlich
weil wie gesagt im Juni du hast das
gerade angesprochen war der letzte
Angriff hier auf Kiew noch nie gab's
einen so wie am Montag mitten ins
Zentrum und das hat viele Menschen hier
natürlich schon verschreckt und
verängstigt und die Schulen
beispielsweise die sind wieder ins
remote lernen übergegangen das kennt man
ja aus corona-zeiten selbst in
Deutschland also da ist man hier
natürlich auch sehr geübt das wird dann
von eben auf gleich hier umgesetzt damit
natürlich die Menschen auch zu Hause
bleiben können um Schutz zu suchen und
das hat also einige hier ja natürlich
erschrocken erschreckt überrascht und
gleichzeitig ist es aber eben auch ein
ein Alltag der die Menschen hier schon
eine Weile begleitet
du bist zusammen mit unserer Kollegin
Katrin Eigendorf in Kiew und
sie hat heute Gelegenheit Präsident
selensky zu interviewen da kurz rein
die Mittel- und Kräfte der russischen
und der ukrainischen Armee lassen sich
nicht vergleichen aber wir haben die
Initiative übernommen und wir kommen
voran
und deshalb greifen Sie uns mit Raketen
an weil sie auf dem Schlachtfeld nichts
erreichen sie wollen uns Angst einjagen
und uns brechen
und dasselbe gilt für die Diplomatie
Drohungen auch damit das ganz Europa
frieren wird Russland erpresst mit
Atomwaffen weil ihnen die Initiative
überlassen wurde
das sind klare Botschaften von selensky
was hat er noch gesagt in diesem
Interview
er hat vor allem natürlich auch
geschlossenheiten Unterstützung
gefordert von Europa hat Europa auch
insofern kritisiert dass er gesagt hat
ich zitiere hier mal also Europa lebt
noch mit dem Gefühl der Angst was wird
Russland tun wie wird Putin Antworten
und was wird passieren wenn Putin nicht
mehr da ist also dass da nach wie vor
noch viel zu sehr darauf gesetzt wird
was tut Putin als nächstes da wünscht er
sich natürlich dass ich davon auch
losgesagt wird und Europa da
entschlossener handelt und reagiert er
hat außerdem auch darüber gesprochen
dass er selbst oder die Ukraine nicht
mit Putin verhandeln wird also das hat
er ausgeschlossen da gibt es keine
Möglichkeit mit Russland ja aber nicht
mit Putin also mit einer anderen Person
das hat er ganz deutlich gemacht im
Gespräch mit Katrin Eigendorf und sich
natürlich aber auch das muss man auch
dazu sagen das war auch noch ein
spannender Punkt sich schon auch für die
Unterstützung Deutschlands bedankt die
Unterstützung des Kanzlers das klang ja
in der Vergangenheit auch mal anders
aber das erkennt er an dass das jetzt
mehr geworden ist die Unterstützung aus
Deutschland
da hat sich das Verhältnis dann doch
geändert vielen Dank Alisa euch
weiterhin alles Gute in Kiew
ja und damit sind wir bei dir Florian
neuhahn du bist unser Korrespondent in
Brüssel wo sich die
Verteidigungsminister der NATO-Staaten
seit heute treffen wir sprechen gleich
vorher hat uns Gunnar Krüger noch mal
das wichtigste zusammengefasst
es heißt Iris t SLM und soll helfen
gegen das was die Ukraine russischen
Terror nennt Luftabwehr in einem Radius
von 40 Kilometern gegen Drohnen und
Raketen verspricht der deutsche
Hersteller bezahlt die deutsche
Bundesregierung das ist nur der Anfang
und wir brauchen mehr schreibt der
Verteidigungsminister der Ukraine mit
Dank an die Kollegin aus Deutschland die
verkündet den Brüssel heute die erste
Lieferung nicht ohne Stolz aber mit
Verzögerung zu dem folgen erst 2023 drei
weitere Systeme
das sind hochkomplexe hochmoderne
Systeme und die brauchen eine gewisse
Zeit aber wir tun alles damit es so
schnell wie möglich geschickt es ist der
Nato-Generalsekretär der druckmacht auf
alle Mitglieder angesichts von Russlands
Angriffswelle
das zeigt alles den dringenden Bedarf
für Luftverteidigung die Verbündeten
haben geliefert aber wir brauchen noch
mehr
es ist nicht die NATO sondern die
sogenannte Rammstein Gruppe aus als 50
Staaten die liefert Vorsitz haben die
USA die auch zwei Systeme versprechen
und weitere auch erst noch produzieren
wir bringen unsere Waffenindustrie nun
zusammen damit Sie dieses Thema
produzieren die die Ukraine braucht ohne
Abstriche an unserer eigenen Sicherheit
winterfest will der Westen die Ukraine
machen klar ist dafür reicht kein Griff
ins Lager dafür braucht es
Kriegsproduktion
und Florian Frage an dich wie
entschlossen hast du die natorte
wahrgenommen der Ukraine weiter zu
helfen
ich glaube da muss man differenzieren
hier auf der Brüsseler Bühne da war die
Entschlossenheit wirklich mit Händen zu
greifen und wirklich auch sehr
überraschend wie groß sie eben war der
US-Verteidigungsminister sprach hier
sogar voreinander inspirierenden
Geschlossenheit auf der Pressekonferenz
vor gut einer Stunde so weit muss man
nicht gehen aber trotzdem das war hier
deutlich ein Signal der Geschlossenheit
von fast 50 Staaten die weiter die
Ukraine unterstützen wollen auf der
anderen Seite aber wenn all diese
Minister dann heute oder morgen nach
Hause reisen werden dann werden sie
wieder konfrontiert werden mit einer zum
Teil ja wachsenden Unzufriedenheit mit
Schwierigkeiten von den Menschen vor Ort
die alle quer durch Europa durch die
NATO Staaten von den hohen
Energiepreisen von den Folgen des
Krieges und damit auch der Sanktionen
betroffen sind und ja wo diese Unruhe
immer mehr zu spüren sein wird auch
durch Wahlergebnisse durch Wahlerfolge
von Rechten populistischen Parteien ob
in Deutschland oder auch zuletzt in
Italien und diese dieser Zwiespalt dir
wiederum ist auch hier in den
Hintergrundgesprächen in Brüssel zu
merken die Sorge dass diese
Geschlossenheit die heute noch hier
präsentiert hat nicht mehr durchzuhalten
ist über diesen ganzen Winter
erinnern wir uns an das Thema dieses
Streams wie die Gegenoffensive in der
Ukraine vorankommt und da hat
US-Verteidigungsminister Orts Osten am
Rande dieses Treffens ist ja auch diese
nato-kontaktgruppe zusammengekommen
gesagt dass die Unterstützung für die
Ukraine nicht vom Ausgang einer
bestimmten Schlacht abhängen würde was
genau meint er damit
ich glaube er meint damit zweierlei zum
einen ist dieser Krieg ein komplexer
Krieg kein Krieg an dem es eine einzige
Schlacht gibt die alles entscheidet es
gibt verschiedene Frontlinien es gibt
Angriffe über den Boden über die Luft
Hybride Angriffe Cyber-Attacken
möglicherweise ja auch die
nato-infrastruktur wenn etwa sich
herausstellen sollte dass Russland
tatsächlich wie viele vermuten hinter
den Angriffen auf die Nord Stream 2 und
1 Pipelines stand und zum zweiten glaube
ich dass er mit einer solchen Bemerkung
sicherlich auch die Öffentlichkeit
darauf einstellen will und muss dass
dieser Krieg nach allem was die USA und
die NATO wissen noch sehr viel länger
dauern wird das ist eben also nicht
jetzt kurz vor der Entscheidung steht
sondern dass ja die USA und die NATO mit
einem sehr langen Krieg möglicherweise
über die nächsten Monate oder gar Jahre
rechnen und darauf muss man wohl aus
seiner Sicht die Öffentlichkeit
einstellen
Florian noch eine Frage an dich die
russischen Atom Drohungen wie ernst
nimmt die NATO die wie bereitet man sich
darauf vor
ja auf jeden Fall nimmt man sie ernst
ich hatte gestern die Gelegenheit zu
einem längeren Interview mit dem
Nato-Generalsekretär Jens deutenberg der
darauf auf diese Frage zwei Botschaften
hatte die eine Botschaft ist die NATO
sieht derzeit keine Veränderung in der
nuklearen Aufstellung Russlands also
keine Vorbereitungen unmittelbar für
einen Nuklearschlag aber auf der anderen
Seite sagt er auch mehrfach in diesem
Interview wir müssen als NATO diese
Rhetorik Putins auf jeden Fall ernst
nehmen das Jahr hat uns gezeigt dass
Putin das was er androht auch
wahrzumachen bereit ist und insofern
sendet die NATO hier auch ein
gleichzeitiges Signal aus auf allen
Kanälen an Russland das Russland bei
einem solchen Nuklearschlag mit
schwerwiegenden Konsequenzen zu rechnen
haben habe ohne das man diese
Konsequenzen näher ausbuchstabiert man
hofft einfach dass diese Drohung seitens
des Westens mit schwerwiegenden
Konsequenzen gehört wird und dass sie
dann Putin von einer solchen ultimativen
Eskalation wirklich auch abhält
vielen Dank für deine Informationen
Florian neuhahn in Brüssel tschüss
ja und damit direkt zu oberst Markus
Reisner Kommandant bei der
österreichischen Armee schönen guten
Abend
guten Abend nach Deutschland
Reisner wir treffen sie auf einem
Truppenübungsplatz bei Salzburg an da
ist die Verbindung nicht ganz optimal
wir sind jetzt ganz hoffnungsfroh und
probieren das trotzdem bleiben wir
direkt beim Westen sie sagen wie der
Krieg ausgeht entscheidet sich nicht in
der Ukraine sondern in den Hauptstädten
des Westens wie meinen sie das
der wesentliche Faktor den wir verstehen
müssen ist dass das Entscheidende ist
die Unterstützung des Westens für die
Ukraine ohne die Unterstützung des
Westens kann die Ukraine diesen Krieg
nicht weiterführen möglicherweise
gewinnen wir haben das schon gesehen
auch in den letzten offensiven bei hakiv
limano auch in Person hier war vor allem
Gerät im Einsatz das ist die meisten
geliefert worden ist Russland heißt es
und Russland versucht nun genau hier
einen Keil hinein zu treiben versucht
nun genau hier in unseren Heimatländern
den Druck zu erhöhen damit diese
Unterstützung des Westens für die
Ukraine endet und damit das Sicht
Russlands Selbstsicherheit aus diesem
Konflikt hervorgehen kann
kommen wir noch mal zu unserer
Hauptfrage heute Gerät die Offensive ins
Stocken und da hat mein Kollege
Christian Volk den aktuellen Stand
zusammengefasst
ein facebook-video aus der Region herson
es soll die Erfolge der Ukraine zeigen
diese Jungs haben sechs sieben Monate
lang an der Befreiung von arcanelske
gearbeitet jetzt hissen sie die Flagge
einer freien und geeinten Ukraine auf
diesem Gebäude sagt der Kämpfer von der
Front im Süden und Osten des Landes gibt
es heute kaum Bilder nach eigenen
Angaben kommt die ukrainische
Gegenoffensive immer langsamer voran
dennoch in der Region Herr Sonn habe man
fünf weitere Orte zurückerobert auch im
Osten gibt es heute wieder heftige
Gefechte russische Truppen Rücken
offenbar weiter auf die strategische
wichtige Stadt bachmut vor der
Gouverneur von Donezk meldet außerdem
sieben Tote bei einem russischen Angriff
auf den Markt deiner Kleinstadt dafür so
sagt es der Gouverneur gebe es keine
militärische Logik
in Kiew freist der Krieg derweil bis zum
Kinderspielplatz nach den heftigen
Raketenangriffen versuchen Sie hier die
Schäden zu beseitigen im Gebäude nebenan
wohnt Soja mit ihrem Sohn durch die
Explosionen sind alle Ihre Fenster
kaputt
ich habe keine Ahnung wie ich das alles
reparieren soll ich muss hier auch im
Winter Leben und der wird sehr hart
Wut und Angst nach den
vergeltungsangriffen moskau ist der
Krieg zurück in allen Teilen des Landes
diese russischen Angriffe seit Anfang
der Woche haben wir jetzt vor allem auf
die zivile Infrastruktur abgezielt warum
und warum jetzt
ja man muss hier verstehen dass Russland
dann einmal versucht hat eine moderate
Invasion durchzuführen das heißt man
wollte eigentlich die Infrastruktur des
Landes erhalten um sie dann selbst
nutzen zu können wir wissen dass das
also nicht funktioniert hat jetzt ist es
so dass aufgrund auch verschiedene
Ereignisse in der näheren Vergangenheit
darunter herausstechens der Angriff auf
die Brücke über die Straße von kerscht
der Druck so groß war auch das Regime
auf der Hardline in Russland dass der
Präsident etwas machen musste und das
erleben wir gerade in der letzten 48
Stunden diese massiven Luftangriffe also
der Russen auf die kritische
Infrastruktur der Ukraine hier ist
wichtig zu verstehen dass diese Angriffe
im Gegensatz zu den angriffenen Monaten
da vor sich ausschließlich auf die
zivile Infrastruktur ausrichten hier
geht es also darum dass man versucht
quasi die Stromversorgung der Ukraine zu
zerstören Kraftwerke anzugreifen warum
weil man hier Druck auf die Bevölkerung
ausüben möchte und dieser Druck soll
dann von der Bevölkerung an die
ukrainische Regierung weitergegeben
werden im Sinne von dieser zwingend
seiner Verhandlungslösung das heißt
russland versucht er sich hier ganz
massiv den Hebel anzusetzen und damit
Angriffe Betrachten der letzten 48
Stunden dann sehen wir dass diese
Angriffe auch nachhaltig Erfolg haben
wir haben gestern Bilder bekommen als
Lemberg dort fehlt also es am Strom zur
Zeit die ukrainischen Behörden arbeiten
mit Hochdruck daran wie das
wiederherzustellen aber die Frage ist
wenn das so weitergeht und die Ukraine
aufgrund des Mangels an luftanwehrsi
nicht dagegen wehren kann dann ist
natürlich ein Anbetracht des Winters mit
seiner leidensvollen Situation zu
rechnen in den nächsten Monaten und wie
groß sehen Sie diese Gefahr dass die
Ukrainerinnen und Ukrainer die ja
weltweit großen Respekt bekommen für
ihren Durchhaltewillen für ihre Moral
dass die dass die kriegsmüde werden und
sagen wir müssen jetzt in Verhandlungen
einsteigen es hilft alles nichts
ich denke das ukrainische Volk hat uns
schon immer wieder überrascht auch der
abverfolg der Kiew oder auch jetzt der
Folge bei den offensiven bei hakiffen
zeigen dass also hier ein ganz aktiver
und starker Nationalstolz hier ist und
auch ein verteidigungswille der Punkt
ist dass die Angriffe bei Russen die
Ukraine eigentlich noch weiter von den
Russen wegtreiben und die Verbitterung
noch größer wird im Wesentlichen und
auch die Entschlossenheit was ich hier
tatsächlich versucht zu versuchen das
Land wieder frei zu kämpfen die Frage
ist natürlich ob diese Angriffe auf die
kritische Infrastruktur nicht weil sie
auch den Effekt erzielen das ist
tatsächlich zu dem Umstand kommt dass
die Energieversorgung jetzt in den
kommenden wintermonen massiv
eingeschränkt ist und das bedeutet
natürlich dass die Ukraine noch mehr
Unterstützung braucht aus dem Westen wo
natürlich die westlichen Bevölkerung
darunter leidet dass sie selbst einen
Rohstoffe Zug erfährt und da ist die
Frage wie resilient ist eigentlich die
westliche Bevölkerung die resilient ist
man im Hinblick darauf die Ukraine
weiter zu unterstützen also die Frage
entscheidet sich wahrscheinlich nicht im
verteidigungsuklinischen Volkes sondern
in der Bereitschaft meistens versuchen
ich verfolgt bei seiner Verteidigung zu
unterstützen
da gibt es direkt eine Frage dazu von
Massin B auf Youtube welche Armee hat
denn die besseren Voraussetzungen für
den Winter
ja eine Armee kann man natürlich nach
verschiedenen Fähigkeiten und Faktoren
kategorisieren was natürlich
heraussticht ist in diesem konkreten
Fall ist Konflikts einerseits der
Umstand dass wir ein 144 Millionen
vollkommen nämlich dass der Russen mit
einem reservierungs mit einem
reservepotenzial von ca 30 Millionen
Menschen und auf der anderen Seite ein
35 Millionen folgt nämlich dass der
Ukraine wenn man auch die Flüchtlinge
schon weggerechnet beide Seiten schicken
Soldaten in den Einsatz diese Soldaten
müssen niedergekämpft werden und das
Problem ist natürlich der Ukraine
solange die Europäer nur Waffen liefern
hat die ukrainische Armee eine gewisse
Grenze die sie in der
Mobilisierungsfähigkeit ausdrückt werden
auf der anderen Seite die russische
Armee scheinbare unerschöpfliche Reserve
Elemente hat solange es keinen Oktober
1917 Moment gibt keine ballastre wollte
oder sonstiges in Russland wird Russland
weiter diesen Kampf fortsetzen mit den
Reservisten die es jetzt eingezogen hat
und mit dem weiteren gekommen und hier
ist das Problem dass die schiere Masse
scheinbar natürlich der ukrainischen
Seite überlegen ist und die Frage ist
inwieweit kann man das kompensieren mit
Waffensystemen und anderen Dingen und
die Entscheidung wird natürlich in den
nächsten Monaten dann auch für uns
sichtbar werden ob das gelingt oder
nicht
auch dazu gibt es eine Frage von Sven
blau wäre die Bildung einer freiheits-
bzw Befreiungsarmee aus Freiwilligen
seitens des Westens ähnlich wie im
spanischen Bürgerkrieg eine Option der
Ukraine der Ukraine zu helfen eben ohne
Kriegspartei zu werden
diese Bestellungen gibt es ja von Beginn
an schon es gab ja diese Legion die
bereits im Einsatz war es gab auch
Freiwillige die hereingekommen sind und
die druckpläne gekämpft haben es gibt
auch jetzt nach wie vor einen Zufluss
die Frage ist natürlich welchen Effekt
erzielt das im Prinzip da eingehend
betrachtet dass das ja überschaubare
Mengen sind wir brauchen also hier im
Prinzip eine Kapazität von mehreren
10.000 sogar 100.000 Soldaten die
tatsächlich einen Effekt herstellen
wollen wenn man das wieder gegenrechnen
dieser schieren scheinbar
unerschöpflichen Anzahl der Reservisten
Russlands die dürfen sie nicht täuschen
lassen von den Bildern der verrosteten
Waffen der betrunkenen Soldaten es ist
einfach die Masse die einen Unterschied
macht und so lange das russische Volk
davon überzeugt ist in einem
Überlebenskampf gegenüber dem Westen zu
stehen wird es diese Reserven einsetzen
können und da ist natürlich entscheidend
wie weit sich das dann rechnerisch
praktisch ausgehen kann im Vergleich mit
der ukrainischen Armee genau also die
Einberufungen von 300.000 russischen
Soldaten läuft in der Ukraine läuft
ebenso die einen Berufung aber
zahlenmäßig liegen dazwischen eben
Welten ich schaue noch mal kurz im Chat
was es noch an Fragen gibt von 7 Adler
nach ihrer Einschätzung würden
Kampfpanzer westlichen Fabrikats einen
deutlichen Unterschied für die Ukraine
bewirken oder braucht es vielleicht mehr
andere Waffensysteme
die Fähigkeit in der Offensive
entsprechend entscheidend bieten zu
können so haben wir das auch gesehen bei
den letzten offensiven entscheidend ist
aber zu verstehen dass der Krieg in
mehreren Domänen geführt wird also wird
nicht zu Lande geführt er wird auch in
der Luft geführt zu sehen im Weltraum
cyberraum oder natürlich im
Informationsraum wo wir die ganze Zeit
teilhaben was ist so wichtig ist zu
verstehen ist dass wir einerseits
taktisch operative Erfolge auf dem
Gefechtsfeld haben die wir auch sehen
also denken Sie an hakiv limano Person
aber wir haben gleichzeitig auch eine
strategische Abnutzung die Russland
gegenüber der Ukraine durchführt und das
ist eben der Angriff dieser
marschflugkörperpolistischen Raketen und
jetzt auch iranischer Drohnen auf die
Infrastruktur der Ukraine der
ukrainische Präsident selbst hatte
wiederholt gesagt dass die Zahl
mittlerweile über 4000 ist die was sie
hier von russischer Seite eingesetzt
worden ist wir wissen immer noch nicht
wie hoch ist der Befüllungsgrad dieser
Arsenale es gibt Indikatoren dass die
Russen also auch versuchen das zu
kompensieren indem sie zum Teil Flieger
der wegwaffensysteme zweckentfremdet als
Boden Raketen einsetzen aber der Punkt
ist das ist natürlich ein entsprechender
Effekt der eine strategische Abnutzung
erzielt das heißt die Ukraine muss wenn
sie nachhaltig kämpfen möchte wie Tiefe
ihres Landes schützen können und dazu
braucht sie effektiv die Fliegerabwehr
und die Lieferung einzelner Systeme sind
ein Tropfen auf den heißen Stein sie
dürfen nicht vergessen es ist eine
riesiges Land wir haben hier also nur
begrenzte Fähigkeiten in diesen
einzelnen kurzmittel und nah und weiten
Systemen in ihrer Wirkung das heißt da
muss es wirklich massiv etwas passieren
um hier nachhaltig diesen Angriffen der
russischen Streitkräfte mittels
marschenkörper und ballistischen Raketen
oder auch Drohnen ein Ende setzen zu
können es gibt jetzt so nach einer
Nachfrage zur Truppenstärke von Master
Tilidin kann die Ukraine überhaupt trotz
aller Waffen ein jahrelangen Krieg mit
ihrer Soldaten Stärke gegen Russland
standhalten
das wird davon abhängen inwieweit die
russische Bevölkerung bereit ist diesen
Angriffskrieg weiter zu führen wenn sie
selbst so als aufgrund der schweren
Verluste zunehmend ins Zweifeln kommt
und die Unterstützung für den
Präsidenten des Regime abbricht dann
natürlich nicht ganz klar aber wenn die
wussten natürlich dabei bleiben weil sie
durch das Regime gesteuert davon
überzeugt sind das Richtige zu tun dann
ist es eben das Problem dass wir diese
Masse an Reservisten diese Reserven
haben die also hier zum Einsatz kommen
und die Ukraine einfach nur begrenzte
Ressourcen hat ja die Ukraine kämpft mit
großer Tapferkeit sie kämpft mit vielen
überraschenden folgen die man so nicht
erwartet hat die auch viele gerade am
Beginn des Videos überrascht hat die
Waffen bilden einen Teil ihres Rückgrats
viele Systeme kommen erst langsam herein
auch zu spät wir haben das schon gesehen
bei den schweren Waffensystemen das
wurde lange diskutiert dann sind sie
noch rechtzeitig gekommen für die
offensiven jetzt sehen wir das bei den
fliegerbärsystemen auch das wurde
eigentlich schon seit Monaten betont
dass man das braucht jetzt durch die
Ereignisse der letzten 48 Stunden wird
uns das jetzt plötzlich wieder bewusst
und natürlich ist die Frage auch wie res
älteste Bevölkerung eine jahrelangen
Krieg durchzustehen und dann natürlich
ist wichtig zu verstehen dass es nicht
an den ukrainen selbst liegt sondern
auch andere Unterstützung des Westens
wie ist es dann weitergeht wenn es
dieser Konflikt wirklich ein blutiger
langer verheerender Konflikt über die
nächsten Jahre werden sollte dazu
schreibt kamink auf Facebook gibt den
Ukrainern maximal Waffen damit die
endlich gewinnen schauen wir noch mal
auf die aktuelle Offensive wie kommt die
ihrer Einschätzung nach voran
ja also Ukraine hat es geschafft im
Sommer wo wir alle gedacht haben
eigentlich oder viele Experten dass es
auf dieser Abnutzungseffekt durch die
Russen durchschlagener Volker ziehen
wird es gab so diese berühmte
klassenschlacht von die sie schauen die
wir Russen gewonnen haben aber die
Ukraine haben es geschafft Kräfte
bereitzustellen die schweren Waffen die
hereingekommen sind und haben dann diese
offensiven begonnen einmal bei hakiv
weiter Folge dann auch bei limern und
dann im Süden der Person diese
offensiven waren sehr schlau und
praktisch sehr gut überlegt angelegt und
haben also dann wirklich gute Erfolge
erzielt hier ist auch eine gewissen
eigentümerik entstanden und eine
Panikreaktion auf der russischen Seite
man hat es sehr gut gesehen in hakiv wo
sie die Russen gedacht haben die Ukraine
stehen zum Teil schon hinter ihnen das
war sehr gut gemacht und sind also dann
diese Richtung Osten geflüchtet und
jetzt haben wir natürlich auch ganz klar
das Problem dass die Ukraine die sich ja
auch von der Versorgungslinien überdehnt
hat weil sie einfach sehr weit auch
schon vorgemarschiert ist sich jetzt
konsolidieren muss und das Problem ist
natürlich dass die Russen immer noch
Kapazitäten haben und diese
Angriffskräfte abzunutzen das heißt es
geht jetzt quasi von der Bewegung wieder
in einen Stellungskrieg zum Teil über in
der letzten Tagen haben wir gesehen dass
es wieder zu Artillerie Duellen kommen
das kommt also zu Gefechten Panzer gegen
Panzer und das Momentum der Offensive
ist zurzeit nicht mehr vorhanden das
kann sich aber natürlich in den nächsten
Tagen und Stunden ändern zurzeit ist
natürlich die Aufmerksamkeit vor allem
auch redet aufgerichtet diese
verheerenden Angriffe der Russe in der
letzten 48 Stunden auf die kritische
Infrastruktur zu unterdrücken mit der
verfügbaren pflegeabwehr die man zu
zweit im Einsatz hat und das bedeutet
dass eben auch Nachschublieferungen
gefährdet sind oder aktuell nicht
funktionieren
genau wenn wir uns die Angriffe Ansehen
der letzten 48 Stunden diese ca 150
marshmallowkörper politischen Raketen
und vor allem auch iranische Drohne die
ich eingesetzt worden sind so ist ganz
interessanter was die Russen angreifen
die Russen versuchen das
Elektrizitätsnetz zu treffen sie
versuchen die Transformatoren zu
zerstören hier gibt es nur eine
begrenzte Anzahl wir sehen aber auch in
zwei Fällen ganz konkret den Angriff auf
Nachschub und transportknotenpunkte auf
der Eisenbahn das Ziel sicher auch
darauf wie die Anschlussversorgung für
die offensiven quasi zum Unterbrechen zu
bringen und hier kommt natürlich jetzt
darauf an wie die Ukraine in der Lage
ist durch alternative Routen den
Nachschub die Versorgung weiter aufrecht
zu halten bzw wie sie auch in der Lage
ist der Stromnetze so am Leben zu
erhalten dass man sie diese Versorgung
weiter auch möglich ist vor mit
Anbetracht des baldigen kommenden
Winters
Eduard hat noch eine Frage auf Youtube
Ex-General Herr Kujat fordert ja keine
weiteren Offensivwaffen an die Ukraine
zu verschicken und wieder den
politischen Weg einzuschlagen wie Sie
das sehen möchte er gerne wissen
und jeder Konflikt da hat er mehrere
Möglichkeiten zu enden eine Ende wäre
der Sieg einer Partei und die
Kapitulation der anderen wenn das nicht
eintritt ist es historisch meistens so
dass die Konflikte in einer gewissen
Phase
einfrieren versteinern also eine
Situation entsteht wie wir es kennen zum
Beispiel aus nord-südkorea und so weiter
es gibt mehr als Szenarien die dieser
Krieg verlaufen kann wichtig ist zu
verstehen dass die Ukraine auch als
Wertschöpfung in Süden und den Osten des
Landes braucht um es Land überhaupt
überleben zu können das ist das eine auf
der anderen Seite haben wir Russland das
ist ja die letzten 20 Jahre des narrativ
aufgebaut und sie sind wieder zurück sie
sind eine Supermacht sie haben also
jetzt angegriffen sie haben diese Ziele
diese Umsetzung und sie können also
nicht einfach aufhören das heißt eine
Situation dass der also im Moment keinen
Ausweg gibt aber das ist ja etwas was
wir historisch immer wieder erlebt haben
man hat dann erkannt dass schlussendlich
nach einer gewissen Erschöpfung auch mal
aufeinander zugehen muss und
Verhandlungen beginnen müssen zurzeit
ist das noch nicht der Fall beide
Kontrahenten liegen sich gegenüber man
muss sich das vorstellen in den Boxkampf
der dann die jede Runde für den wieder
nach Punkten gewonnen aber wir haben
noch kein KO gesehen und die Frage ist
wie lange geht das weiter das kann also
noch länger dauern oder auch nicht wir
werden das sehen die Historiker werden
versuchen dann wahrscheinlich zu
erklären dass das alles völlig klar war
es ist nicht Geschichte ist nie linear
wir leben gerade Geschichte und der
Ausgang des Konflikts und das ist das
Tragische ist noch völlig offen
es verläuft auch es gibt auch Kämpfe bei
bachmut wie ist da die aktuelle Lage
ist im Prinzip eine Fortsetzung der
russischen Strategie der zweiten Phase
die zweite Phase war also die
schwergewichtsbildung im Don Pass wo man
dann versucht hat eine ganz andere
Taktik anzuwenden wie man das vorher
gemacht hat in der ersten Phase bei Kiew
und beim Einmarsch also man hat nicht
quasi mit den Kräften schmalen und
schnell und tief weiter vorgestoßen
sondern man hat es auch massive
Artillerieeinsatz zuerst vorher
angestellt und ist dann quasi langsam
vorfühlend mit der eigenen Infanterie
formagiert es kommt das Problem
natürlich zu tragen dass die Russen zu
wenig Infanterie haben etwas das sie
seit Beginn des Krieges quasi als
Nachteil mitziehen und im Raum des
don-bus wo auch diese
kesselschlachtbeliese Chance
stattgefunden hat versucht man also
gerade durch den Einsatz von Artillerie
die ukrainischen Stellungen sturmreif zu
schießen man muss verstehen dass die
Ukraine dort ein Tief gestaffeltes
Verteidigungssystem haben die haben die
Russen zum Teil die erste Linie
durchbrochen stehen zum Teil in der
zweiten Linie der bachmut so scheint es
dürften sie weiter voran kommen auch
unter den Einsatz das sollten wir von
Wagner und es ist natürlich
das Problem dass es schlussendlich
irgendwann die ukrainen regional die
Kraft ausgehen könnte vor allem weil sie
also diesen massiven artilleriensatz
ausgesetzt haben das wirklich verheerend
ist man kann sich das nicht vorstellen
das sind können Sie die Bilder
betrachten das ist im Biber Teil 1916
also Dinge die unsere Urgroßvater erlebt
haben und das zum wirkt natürlich und
macht es den Russen möglich temporär
auch Fortschritte zu ziehen die Taktik
der Ukraine zielt vor allem darauf mit
den offensiven in anderen Räumen die
Russen im Prinzip abzulenken und zu
einer Verlagerung der Kräfte zu bewegen
das ist aber noch nicht der Fall und
darum ist es so dass im Park Mut
momentan es wieder zu einem regional
begrenzten aber doch passierenden
Vorstoß der Russen kommt dann vielleicht
noch mal zusammenfassend was braucht die
Ukraine konkret vom Westen damit eben
solche Kämpfe gewonnen werden können
wenn wir als Westen als freie
demokratische Wertegemeinschaft für das
stehen was die Ukraine auch
repräsentiert nämlich ein demokratisches
System eine demokratische Regierung dann
braucht die Ukraine vor allem die
Unterstützung des Westens bei der
Fortführung des Krieges gehen sie quasi
gegen das totalitärische mit diesem Fall
Russlands führt Russland das zum dritten
Mal die Ukraine überfallen hat nach der
Wegnahme der Krim nach den kämpfenden
separatistengebieten 2014 nun dieser
massive Angriff und das ist die
entscheidende Frage die wir uns auch als
Westen stellen wollen wollen wir das
zulassen dass etwas in dieser Form
passiert wo wir gerade nach Ende des
Zweiten Weltkrieges mit den
Entwicklungen im Völkerrecht gesagt und
das gehört der Vergangenheit an oder
nicht daran und dieser Grundsatzfrage
wird sich im Prinzip entscheiden mit
dieser Krieg weiter verlaufen wird
und was meinen Sie genau mit
Unterstützung
Unterstützung ist natürlich einerseits
das was wir gerade sehen also was auch
im Rahmen verschiedener Konferenzen ob
das der NATO ist oder auch im Rahmen der
Europäischen Union passiert das ist
einerseits Unterstützung mit
Waffensystemen aber natürlich auch mit
finanziellen Mitteln und der Ukraine das
Überleben der nächsten Monate zu
ermöglichen das ist das eine und wenn
man natürlich daran denkt und dass er
sich am Beginn gesagt hat das russland
versucht natürlich gerade einen Keil in
die Unterstützung zu bringen zwischen
ganz Europa unter der Ukraine da muss
man natürlich verstehen dass es vor
allem die moralische Unterstützung geht
für die Ukraine die dort diesen Krieg
führen sie dürfen nicht vergessen wenn
Russland den Konflikt von heute auf
morgen beenden würde dann wäre dieser
Krieg vorbei wenn die Ukraine diesen
Konflikt von heute auf morgen weniger
dann gäbe es keine Ukraine mehr und das
ist ein entscheidender Unterschied
noch mal eine letzte Frage der
ukrainische präsidentenberater aristovic
hat in einem Interview mit der Zeit
gesagt dass Putin im Februar taktische
Atomwaffen einsetzen könnte das ist
seine Einschätzung seine Befürchtung wie
sehen Sie das
in Russland spielt natürlich mit unseren
Ängsten deren sind vor allem drei Dinge
das eine ist die mangeln Getreideexporte
die möglicherweise zu einer hohe
Situation führen eine globalen dazu
führen dass man ins Video zu einem
Migrationswelle kommt das ist das eine
das zweite ist natürlich die Frage
Wirtschaft wir werden uns europäischen
Wirtschaft und das aushalten dass sie
nicht nur diese zwei Prozent der
Rohstoffe bekommen oder nicht ja das
können wir auch jetzt nicht daraus
machen
bei diesem Kraftwerk sondern auch der
Einsatz von taktischen Atomwaffen ich
glaube es muss uns allen bewusst sein
dass die Großmächte die wir diese
Fähigkeiten verfügen aus den letzten
Jahrzehnten gelernt haben das heißt das
heißt also jeder wird sicher darauf
beachten eine derartige Eskalation zu
vermeiden selbst bei dem regionalen
Einsatz von taktischen Atomwaffen bin
ich mir sicher dass es Mechanismen gibt
die versuchen das einzulegen weil es
wäre fast dieser Spinne
Eskalation gibt die wir momentan noch
nicht erkennen können denn mit den
Angriffen der Russen auf die
Infrastruktur haben die Russen ja
gezeigt dass sie durchaus noch
Fähigkeiten haben das heißt es gibt für
sie keinen Notwendigkeit als taktischer
Dom auf einzusetzen aber sie setzen es
natürlich im Informationsraum ein in
einer Drogerie so wie ich es vorher
angesprochen habe und das macht uns
natürlich nervös in Europa weil wir das
nicht einordnen können wir hören
voneinander nuklear Übung wir hören
davon dass Raketen an die Grenze verlegt
werden wir hören davon das Ergebnis sich
öffnen und wir haben natürlich Angst
dazu muss man auch wissen dass die
Russen selbst auch eine Strategie
entwickeln kann die sich nennt
eskalieren und zu deeskalieren das heißt
man versucht quasi den Druck zu erhöhen
stellen Sie sich vor wie zwei sitzen in
einem Boot ja ich sage Ihnen ich möchte
was von ihnen haben oder ich werfe über
Bord sie sagen das glaube ich ihnen
nicht ich beginne das Boot zu schütteln
und zu Beuteln wie sie vorher Angst
haben okay bitte hören Sie auf ich du
alles was sie wollen und genau diese
Situation sind wir sie versuchen also
einfach enormen Druck auszuüben weil sie
glauben dass unsere Gesellschaften nicht
resilient dekadent und auch nicht
durchhaltefähig sind im Gegensatz zu
ihrer letztes Jahr an das ist der wunde
Punkt den wir haben unsere Achillesferse
jetzt bin ich ganz froh dass die
Verbindung doch super stabil war im
Großen und Ganzen ich danke Ihnen sehr
für dieses spannende Gespräch und
wünsche Ihnen noch einen schönen Abend
tschüss
damit beenden wir unseren Stream und
bedanken uns auch bei Ihnen und Euch
ganz herzlich für die Fragen und
Kommentare einen schönen Abend